SPEAKER: Say you've
got a vision,
the next big IoT device that
will revolutionize the way
people interact with all of
their household appliances.
With your new IoT device--
and let's call it Smart Fridge--
connected refrigerators will be
able to predict when foods will
go stale and even automatically
reorder those items directly
from a grocer to keep
the stock up to date.
It's all flawless.
You know exactly what it
will do and who needs it.
But once you get that product
in the hands of millions-- no,
billions-- how will you handle
the vast amounts of data that's
going to come pouring in?
Have you figured out how to
collect, process, and analyze
all of your IoT data?
You may want to consider
using Cloud IoT Core.
Cloud IoT Core is a
fully managed service
that allows you to easily
and securely connect, manage,
and ingest data from millions
of globally dispersed devices.
How does it work?
Well, let's head
over to Qwiklabs.
In the lab, building an IoT
analytics pipeline on Google
Cloud Platform, you'll
learn how to ingest
the stream of information from
Cloud IoT Core using Cloud
Pub/Sub, process all that
data using Cloud Dataflow,
connect and manage MQTT-based
devices using Cloud IoT Core.
And for the purposes
of this lab,
we'll be using
simulated devices.
Lastly, you'll be able to
analyze all of that IoT data
using Google BigQuery.
And you can use
your IoT data stream
for things like advanced
analytics, visualizations,
and even machine
learning, which is
gonna help you improve
operational efficiency,
anticipate problems, and
build rich models that
will help you better describe
and optimize your business.
The lab will take you less
than an hour to complete,
and it'll give
you an opportunity
to see if Cloud IoT
Core is going to be
a good fit for Smart Fridge.
Qwiklabs is an online,
hands-on lab library
with more than 150 labs
in every Cloud topic,
ranging from introductory
to guru level.
Each lab will help you learn
a new skill in about an hour
using Google Cloud.
When you're ready,
use the link below
to take the lab that we
just went through today.
And if you're ready to sign
up for GCP, look for that link
below, and you can apply a
$300 credit to your account.
Today I'll be responding
to a request from Dan Pham
from one of our
previous episodes.
Dan writes in and says,
"Great video for Kubernetes
newbies and a nice
segue into how you can
run all of your apps on GCP.
I'd love to see some
more customer success
stories about
companies who are using
a microservice
architecture instead
of traditional
monolithic stacks."
Definitely.
And thanks for writing in, Dan.
We have many customer
stories using Google Cloud,
and they're on our Google
Cloud customer page.
There you can discover why
the world's most innovative
organizations are choosing
to run their applications
on Google Cloud.
A customer story that I
like and you can check out
is Dolphin Technologies.
And they say, "We moved to a
dockerized, container-based,
microservices architecture
with Google Kubernetes Engine
in just three months.
That really paid off for us.
Instead of worrying
that our systems are up,
we know that they're
up, no question."
And if you have a question
or comment for us,
let us know in the
comments section below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]